welcome back to las vegas now the 2022
las vegas metropolitan police department
k9 calendar is officially available for
purchase and not only do you get your
hands on it because it features these
amazing canines but it also supports our
community in a lot of ways so thank you
to the lvmpd foundation for sponsoring
today's segment and joining us is
officer mike moreno and his canine
partner spanky thanks for bringing
spanky thanks for having us i'm excited
you're here but i'm really excited
savanky's here that's usually how it
goes part of the show
well let's talk about this calendar and
just why it's so important to support
and what it does for the community so
the proceeds from the calendar they go
to benefit the lvmpd foundation and that
supports hundreds of initiatives and
programs that help make and keep our
community safe one of those is the lvmpd
canine section it helps not only our
active dogs but also our retired
partners as well
and people can purchase these now right
they're available where can you get them
you can get them on the lvmpd foundation
website and they also have a storefront
kiosk at the fashion show mall that if
you're i mean santa's only a couple days
away so ups may not have time go down
and visit them at the fashion show it's
the perfect gift to get for the holidays
and we have to talk about spanky here
for a minute tell me all about him so
spanky is a five-year-old springer
spaniel he is a narcotics detection dog
we've been partnered up now for almost
two years and he's just he's a he's a
great dog he's a great detection dog
he's a little ball of fire i
he's well behaved right now
i know he's he's pretty comfortable here
on las vegas now
and does spanky make an appearance in
the calendar this year spanky is mr
december oh the perfect month for the
holidays and i have to ask i was looking
through some of the photos in the
calendar was it hard to get the dogs to
pose i mean these are the most
well-trained dogs there are but those
poses were amazing look at that yeah so
you think taking your your toddler to
jcpenney to do christmas christmas
photos is rough try doing a photo shoot
with the dog
it's challenging but you know the the
photographer uh matt mccarthy he he does
a great job in capturing these dogs and
he's they they look amazing yeah we're
looking at these photos here and just
one is better than like they're sneaky
look at it she's a model oh my gosh i
just i could look at these all day this
is the perfect holiday gift to get and
just thank you for everything you do in
our community and keeping us safe and
everyone out there go grab a calendar
and uh spanky is sleeping oh nope he's
awake we've made him very comfortable
here
all of your information is on the screen
be sure to get your 2022 canine calendar
for more information you can visit the
lvmpdfoundation.org
thank you so much for being here thanks
for having us that was really cute thank
you